for the third day of Christmas we've got
something quite special
we've got three pins of elements the one
that was given to me this year is the
third one here which has the element tin
on it the element tin is number 50 on
the periodic table these pins all come
from Moscow State University where I'm
an honorary professor and every year
they have for the last 50 years they've
celebrated the day of the chemists gene
chemica for the first one they had a
badge with hydrogen on it
element number one and then each year
they've gone one place along the
periodic table the first time I came
across it was in 1990 when they go to
element number 25 which is molybdenum
and I got to pin then and then in 1991 I
got another one
iron which is 26 and then there's been
quite a gap I have had a few but this
year is number 50 and I got a special
gold one I also got a book which shows
all of these badges hydrogen helium
lithium and so on so you can see here's
my molybdenum and iron badges they
haven't got the colors quite right for
the iron and then over here is tin
they're tin badge looks different from
mine I've got a special edition gold one
whereas ordinary people got a coloured
one it's really nice that any chemistry
department should have such a long
tradition every year celebrating
chemistry so for the third day of
Christmas we have three chemical bag
two periodic table bed covers and one
piece of tartaric acid from a Swiss wine
barrel let's see what we have for day
four
and got up to a few other adventures on
the way but I'm guessing that this here
is representing the earth Koran and this
golden orb here in the middle is the Sun
isn't is yes and here it's interesting
that I mean Venus is about the same size
as the earth but we have here a tiny
little dot